bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite le sommaire de
cette émission le son du coin lance une
opération de promotion de la scène
locale une démarche de soutien à la
campagne votons plus de musique dans nos
villes ou 2014 toutes les précisions
avec notre invité dans quelques instants
la 13e édition du festival du cirque des
mureaux accueilli 46 artistes de
renommée internationale numéro revisité
grands classiques toutes les tendances
été présenté le 8 mars la ferme de bel
ébat à guyancourt présente neige noire
une adaptation en jeux de la musique de
la vie de billie holiday nicolas gervais
a rencontré christine qu'est la metteur
en scène
il est passionné de web et de musique
son leitmotiv soutenir la scène musicale
locale c'est ainsi qu'il crée en 2012 le
site le sous-menu coin on se farcir et
vermandel alors le son du point c'est un
site gratuit
d'écouté de musique en streaming dédié
aux artistes locaux plus généralement on
va dire aux artistes indépendants de la
région dont vous l'avez créé ce site en
alors avant qu'on parle justement de
la de l'opération vous avez lancé de
soutien donc à cette scène locale
j'aimerais qu'on revienne justement sur
l'histoire du site quel est son principe
voilà son tranchant que seulement alors
le principe ça fonctionne comme comme
une plateforme de streaming comme on
peut en voir beaucoup en ce moment
oui il va il est dédié aux artistes
locaux donc il a d'abord été ouverts
dans les yvelines et maintenant ils
s'ouvrent à plusieurs départements donc
le but étant de couvrir les artistes
d'île de france pour faire une promotion
sur les artistes les artistes locaux par
ville pour que chacun puisse voir qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans sa ville d'où viennent
d'où viennent les artistes qu'il aime
bien d'où vient un artiste qui veut qui
peut voir jouer dans samedi c'est donc
là ses visiteurs et visiteurs il vient
utilisation
on a été un concert dans une salle de sa
ville et puis on va retrouver le groupe
et via des suggestions peut aussi
découvrir d'autres groupes qui viennent
de la ville d'à côté où l'art et les
artistes
bas celle inverse du coup puisque le
site s'adresse à un public
essentiellement locale donc c'est un
public qui va se déplacer pour les voir
en concert ou acheter leurs albums
l'inconvénient des grosses plateformes
comme deezer ou spotify par exemple
c'est qu'on est noyé dans la masse des
artistes internationaux et même si c'est
bien aussi d'avoir une visibilité
internationale s'est pas forcément des
artistes qui vont s'engager donc là on
s'attaque vraiment un public local et le
site est gratuit et est aussi avocat
consulté par les programmateurs et les
professionnels de la région qui vont
faire aussi leur marché quand ils ont
besoin d'un groupe local
une vitrine ça accroît la visibilité et
du coup c'est romas une promotion
vraiment ciblées voilà c'est ça combien
pour avoir quelques chiffres combien
d'euros alors pour l'instant un peu plus
de 400 euros
principalement sur les ive et le numéro
scène ce que les deux autres
départements qui sont renversés du val
d'oise et l'essonne sont en vigueur
depuis début janvier donc ça commence un
petit à petit mais donc plus de 400
groupes sur deux départements d'accord
et en terme de écoute en termes d écoute
on est à peu près 5000 écoute par mois
et 2000 visiteurs tous les mois
ces chiffres démontrent que toutes les
formes d'écouté de pratiques médicales
connaissent un véritable engouement ces
dernières années toutefois on peut noter
que les structures les lieux de
diffusion ou les salles les écoles de
musique les studios de répétition
viennent à manquer parfois dans
certaines villes et on peut même pas
parler de désert musicaux donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle les acteurs du rif
alors le rif c'est le réseau de musique
en ile de france se mobilise pour que
les enjeux liés aux musiques actuelles
soient présentes dans le cadre des
élections municipales on est en plein
dedans en ce moment et c'est comme ça
que la campagne votons plus de musique
dans nos villes en 2014 est lancé vous
soutenez cette démarche cheryl oui
complètement
alors ben en fait
je propose donc sur le son du coin un
album à télécharger gratuitement donc en
mp3 d'artistes inscrits sur le site et
pour de vous faire la promotion de des
artistes des artistes indépendants de la
région parce que dans cette campagne on
parle beaucoup de ce tube de répétition
de table de ce concert de subventions
mais je trouvais ça bien de remettre un
peu de musique dans ce débat de montrer
quels sont les artistes qui vont
utiliser les studios de répétition quels
sont les artistes qui vont se produire
sur sur ces scènes sur ces scènes
municipal et donc voilà de présenter de
présenter la scène locale sous forme de
dons à lomé télécharger gratuitement bah
écoutez moi je vous propose qu'on
regarde un extrait de cette compilation
6 qui est le souhait
ah ah
et
je le dois qu'à bout et jean défaire ce
qui n'est pas vous donner pour mon père
allant du monde sous
oh
aso
alors on a pu voir là donc cinq des
groupes dont qui figurent dans cette
compilation y en a combien au total
alors sur la compilation est téléchargée
1 à 20 et on a aussi un album à écouter
en streaming sur le sens du coin avec 51
morceau cette fois voilà il ya deux
versions une version courte à
télécharger est une version plus longue
donc 51 groupe et cette fois ci c'est en
streaming alors sur ses vingt groupes
vous avez donc dû faire une sélection
s'il pose donc là on a vu que c'est
assez éclectique un haut niveau des
genres mais sur quelles bases vous les
avez sélectionné ces propos alors c'est
assez difficile mais je suis pas
oui parce qu'on ne pouvait pas pour des
raisons techniques ne pouvait pas mettre
5 entre morceaux à télécharger ce
n'était pas possible mais mais je vais
aussi donner c'est bien de donner aussi
l'occasion à tous les groupes qui
veulent soutenir la campagne de d'être
visible ce temps je m'attendais pas à
voir autant oui pascal thurre voilà on
rappelle les groupes postuler
qui soutiennent
sur cette compilation
alors bas j'ai essayé de
garder certains équilibres des équipes
de gens pour que tous les styles soit à
peu près représenter un peu de métal un
peu de reggae chanson électro
j'ai essayé de faire en sorte comme la
compagnie régionale
j'essaie de faire en sorte que les robes
les départements sont aussi représentés
dans les quatre départements où véro
sans doute
c'était assez difficile parce que deux
sont très présents
très équilibré voilà un excellent
équilibre aussi de niveaux met des
groupes un peu plus connus et en même
temps des nouveaux groupes qui ont du
potentiel et après bah c'est aussi des
coups de coeur personnel d un des
groupes qui soutiennent le projet depuis
le début j'avais envie de mettre en
alors on rappelle voilà donc la version
courte des 20 titres et donc à
télécharger librement c'est gratuit tout
ça sur le site sont du coin point fr il
ya une petite rubrique vote ont plus de
musique donc dans nos vies puisque c'est
le soutien de cette campagne et puis
également donc le au même endroit on
trouve également le l'album à écouter en
streaming et là ce sera donc 51 titres
quand un morceau merci série la merci de
venir sur notre plateau alors on va
passer maintenant on quitte donc la
scène musicale pour rejoindre la piste
du cirque puisque la 13e édition du
festival du cirque des mureaux accueilli
samedi et dimanche dernier 46 artistes
internationaux de renommée donc mondial
numéro revisité grands classiques toutes
les tendances et est présenté sous
chapiteau image d' anthony rech le temps
d'un week end sous le chapiteau installé
parc du sceau tour une quarantaine
d'artistes ont paradé dans l'arène entre
disciplines traditionnelles et le héros
moderne de festival du cirque des murs
ont créé
sous l'impulsion de la commune est
devenu l'un des plus renommés en ile de
france un mouvement populaire et
familial qui pour cette 13e édition
maintient une politique tarifaire
attractive avec des places comprise
entre 5 et 12 euros des artistes venus
du monde entier ont fait valoir leur
talent sous la houlette de monsieur
loyal cette année encore en charge de la
programmation d'apporter un vrai un beau
spectacle de cirque à la portée de
toutes les bourses c'est dire que les
familles des plus les les moins riches
qui peuvent pas se payer des places à 45
euros ou à 50 euros voire 60 parfois
puissent voir le même spectacle un tarif
à la portée de tous parce que le rêve
appartient à tout le monde et c'est
aussi le cirque le seul endroit le sel
c'est le seul que j'avais ça le cercle
d'amour parce que c'est le seul endroit
où il y avait une véritable
intégration et acceptation de toutes
nationalités
toute religion toute mentalité quelle
qu'elle soit pour la première fois aux
mureaux la troupe eagles des artistes
gabonais nous présenter la spécialité
l'acrobatie qui ont commencé avec un
sentiment de fierté de femmes et savoir
qu' on peut s'intéresser à la culture
japonaise le cirque peut y être africain
tout est exécuté avec la danse africaine
de la danse africaine peut être ouverte
à n'importe quel la numéro revisités aux
grands classiques le cirque pour essence
de créer des émotions chez le spectateur
ou prouesse technique qui exploit au
toit création artistique et
chorégraphique
nous sommes encore en période de
vacances scolaires alors voici une
illustration d'un atelier pour enfants
il s'agissait de confectionner des
déguisements de super héros parce que
oui avant d'être un super héros mais il
faut avoir un bon déguisements images
dès la 10 mois
qui n'a pas rêvé d'avoir des pouvoirs
extraordinaires pendant une semaine
l'estaminet à magny les hameaux invité
les enfants à façonner leur costume de
super héros selon leur imagination
ils ont dessiné les différents éléments
du déguisement on m'avait demandé du
coup de venir faire une semaine de
création de costumes de super-héros en
essayant de changer un petit peu les
codes des super héros pas forcément
venir faire le costume de batman de
spider man ou voilà mais plutôt de
s'approprier le super héros à soi les
enfants ont appris les bases de la
couture ils sont prêts à rééditer cette
expérience chez eux
parce que après
maintenant mathieu ne pourra leur faire
et s'il vient de leur faire comme ça on
pourra le donner à quelqu'un d'autre et
croit que l approche de mardi gras les
enfants pourront jouer les apprentis
justicier avec leurs propres costumes
retrouvons santé atteindre nicolas
gervais pour sa chronique dans la casc
le 8 mars journée de la femme la ferme
de bel ébat présente neige noire un
spectacle entre théâtre et musique ou
prestine pouquet metteur en scène met
donc en scène la vie d'une des plus
grandes de chanteuse de jazz billie
holiday
elle signe un ovni musical et théâtral
librement adapté de la vie cabossée de
billie holiday et elle sera le 8 mars à
l'occasion de la journée de la femme à
la ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt voici
christine bouquet dans le kiosque on y
va c'est parti c'est par la petite foule
etc
le terrain
billie holiday quand j'ai découvert
cette héroïne et chanteuse musicienne à
la vie complètement cabossée je me suis
dit que c'était une
trésor incroyable pour écrire une
histoire de femmes pour les femmes sur
les femmes où il est question de la
difficile rencontre avec l'homme où il
est difficile est difficile de se
retrouver quand on a été violée à l'âge
de 13 ans elle est née à une époque qui
hélas le temps de la ségrégation raciale
en 1915 et delahaye donc il était aussi
important de parler de toute cette
thématique qui sont chères au coeur
racisme au sexisme
voilà pourquoi je me suis intéressé à
son histoire plier comme celle de toutes
les chanteuses de blues de cette époque
là à peu près le même furieux
c'est vers papa que je veux aller vers
mon père ça prendra le temps que ça
prendra mais je finirai par le coincer
quelques mares
ce qu'il me dise si mon chat c'est du
lard ou du cochon du ce n'est pas une
histoire avec effectivement un début un
milieu et une fin ce n'est pas une
histoire qui est écrite dans le temps de
façon chronologique est logique mais au
contraire dans une histoire qui est en
mouvement rythmée par la musique pas
avec un trio donc
que j'ai sollicité le trio michel pas ce
qui est lui même amoureux de la musique
de cette époque de les stores yong et
j'ai eu cette chance incroyable de
tomber sur ce trio piano basse batterie
jazz et sur des interprètes qui sont
chanteuses comme chanteuse comédienne
pour interpréter les chansons de billie
holiday en anglais et elle s'est
inspirée billie holiday pour écrire ses
textes de ce qu'elle vivait elle
dans sa vie donc c'est absolument
prodigieux comme source d'inspiration
pour l'écriture moi je verrais bien chez
duke et les mutants
du moment moi mes deux coqueluches ces
baby smith est louis armstrong
je vais écouter dans le salon d'aller
sur le vieux phonographe
en échange de pouce pour les filles qui
attendait le client
ne faudrait pas que le mac
cette création est un ovni
ce n'est ni une comédie musicale
pourtant il ya des chansons ce n'est ni
une pièce de théâtre classique pas avec
une histoire chronologique mais des
anecdotes qui sont très fortes
ce n'est ni une une tragédie mais c'est
tout ça à la fois oui parce que ça
chante ça danse et sa pâle mes fils
karim on a du cran
avec des fils mise et les autres aux
nogentais coût peu élevé des femmes
librement et même couché avec elle si ça
vous plaît
et mais les spurs se recoucher avec lui
si ça vous plaît c'est quoi ce chic que
tu vas jouer dans l'accueil qu'engendre
c'est quoi ce rouge à lèvres sur ton col
de chemise
je sais
inclus
europe 1
le 8 mars c'est avec rémy quotas et
dominique magloire dominique magloire
que je connais depuis gains avant ce
vote bien évidemment qui est une femme
artiste avec une voix et une nonchalance
en scène une aura de diva qui a impulsé
aussi ce projet cette rencontre
artistique avec cette femme j'avais
vraiment envie en plus de changer
l'image de la femme telle qu'on peut la
concevoir grande blonde est mince son
partenaire qui est un double masculin
j'ai eu envie d'écrire ce texte avec une
comme un peul jiminy cricket 1 10 min
cricket qui est là pour rétablir
l'histoire mais là ce que tu dis c'est
pas vrai c'est pas la vérité mais qui
est là pour recadrer l'histoire et il
est pris au piège de cette femme il va
jouer tous les personnages que bibi a
connu le proxénète
le mari l'amant et le fameux geste ryong
le seul à me sens le saxophoniste de
jazz qu'elle qu'elle va rencontrer
ce tube just lui
séparables comme deux au dessus des
nuages bleus au dessus des toits loin
d'être rares
loin des canons de planches qui veulent
brûler
jusqu'à là
cette création s'adresse à un très large
public à partir je dirais des 10 aux et
touche pour nous adultes nos coeurs
d'enfants nos âmes d'enfant parce que
bon la musique le blues le jazz on a
peut-être oublié les racines du jazz
viennent des champs de coton bien
évidemment et on a peut-être oublié que
c'était les chanteurs noirs qui étaient
dans les champs de coton esclave
l'esclavagisme et dénoncé dans ce
spectacle si parce qu'il ya encore de
l'esclavagisme en 2014 par le biais de
l'humour de la poésie de la danse et du
chant
nous avons vraiment pensé que c'était le
bon car j'ai vraiment pensé que c'était
le chemin à suivre pour séduire un
public qu'est ce que je fais du théâtre
pour partager avant tout des émotions je
crois que si on passe à côté de ça
qu'est ce que c'est que la revivre
et voilà et après neige noire on
retrouve le soleil du kiosque aurélia
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro d' elodie moi
je vais trouver sa superbe
magnifique des acteurs meryl streep
vraiment formidable
très beau film est un film d'action
comme on l'imaginé c'est très réussi sur
le plan de l'action maintenant
c'est pas extraordinaire sur le sur le
plan psychologique mais c'est un film
d'action qui est bien pour ça je trouve
ça très très bien enfin j'ai passé un
film d'action
deux suspects un film plein d'humour
plein non sens des artistes géniaux
plein d'invités aussi des clins d'oeil
enfin onirique onirique
humoristique et en même temps sans c'est
vraiment très original très bon film on
a bien rigolé et j'espère que ça va
aider ceux qui sont qui ont cette
maladie voilà mais non c'est un bon
moment c'était un film cool
qui quand on peut te connaissais pas ce
que ce genre de comportement en fait des
supers qu'on dirait que
j'ai pensé que
j'en fais du bien mais même s'il n'est
pas j'ai eu peur je trouvais que c'était
une fois kébé après j'ai adoré j'ai
adoré le jeu
c'était vraiment formidable je me suis
bien marré abattu était très bien
c'était très rigolo c'était très sympa à
sanaa bien c'était sympa on a bien on a
bien rigolé puis je suis père bien
effectivement pas dit qu'il est comme ça
dans la vie
alors après vos avis sur les sorties
ciné nous nous interrogeons également du
point de vue du professionnel du cinéma
et cette semaine c'est cyril haddad de
projectionniste à l'espace philippe
noiret aux clayes-sous-bois qui nous
livre son coup de coeur
cette semaine le coup de coeur de
l'espace philippe noiret et le film mea
culpa réalisé par fred cavayé avec
vincent lindon et gilles lellouche ils
incarnent deux personnages franck et
simon et franck et simon donc sont deux
policiers qui sont basés sur toulon leur
vie va basculer un soir suite à un
accident de voiture fred va en ressortir
inde m alors que alors que simon lui
sous l'emprise de l'alcool était au
volant et du coup on va ressortir
grièvement blessé sa vie va se trouver
bouleversée il va perdre sa famille et
va perdre son job de flics quelques
années plus tard son fils théo est
témoin d'un règlement de compte et fera
l'objet de menaces
simon va tout faire pour le protéger et
se essayer de retrouver les personnes
qui le qui le poursuivent ce film marque
les retrouvailles de fred cavayé avec
les deux acteurs vincent lindon et
gilles lellouche sur une idée originale
d'olivier marchal mea culpa ne laisse
aucun répit aux spectateurs et ce film
s'inscrit en fait dans le polar
populaire qui ravira les fans de ce type
de film et ce film est donc à découvrir
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
prévost même famille main
c'est quelque chose qui n'aurait pas les
voir
les vacances ne sont pas encore tout à
fait fini alors vous propose quelques
idées de sorties en famille tout d'abord
la découverte de la vie quotidienne des
grands mammifères et soins aux animaux
chèvres moutons vaches aux cochons ce
sera jeudi 27 février à la ferme
pédagogique de la base de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines ont juste
cette journée là pour fêter la
réouverture du parc de france miniature
donc à elancourt en plus de la visite et
du circuit autour des maquettes
attention place au jeu vous pouvez en
famille ou entre amis profiter des jeux
de plateau de cartes de stratégie qui
sont mis à disposition jusqu'au 2 mars
le centre culturel la barbacane à ben
propose samedi 1er mars dès 23h et oui
écoutez bien une nuit de cinéma au
programme trois films albator gravity
haye frankenstein
restauration sur place et petit déjeuner
pour les plus éveillés après le
troisième film c'est à dire à peu près
vers 6h du matin voilà notre émission
maintenant terminer je vous retrouve
donc et la semaine prochaine en direct à
18h30 à mercredi
un petit